alors merci beaucoup pour l'invitation
et écoutez je me suis dit que
probablement la plupart d'entre eux
regroupent parfait de biologie
moléculaire depuis un certain nombre
d'années
alors je commençais ça assez de base
c'est notre corps il est fait de deux
milliards de cellules et dans chacune de
ces deux là il ya un noyau comme celui
ci qui contiennent l'information
génétique qui fait que vous avez les
cheveux blonds les yeux bleus ou que
vous avez une maladie héréditaire
donc c'est important donc c'est un
schéma du noyau de la cellule avec un
noyau à l'intérieur qui contient le
matériel génétique qui est en fait de
l'adn et sept à derna est organisé sous
forme de chromosomes et les chromosomes
on les voit pas habituellement dans les
cellules comme telles que je les ai
montré tantôt les chromosomes on les
voit juste contre les cellules sont en
division alors on a vingt paires de
chromosomes et des des chromosomes xy 22
paires plutôt de chromosomes ni
chromosome sexuel x et y
alors si chromosomes là en fait c'est un
long fil d'adn qui contient
l'information génétique cette
information génétique là l écho des
justes par quatre nucléotides c'est un
peu comme dans oz ordinateur vous avez
des héros vidéo nous aurons un système
un peu plus moderne qui utilisent trop
bien dire qu'elle utilise quatre lettres
différentes plutôt que jose 2 alors en
fait ce génome humain il est constitué
de 3.3 milliards de nucléotides et ça
constitue un long fil qui ferait 30
mètres de longueur et qu'on réussit à
rentrer dans un petit noyau qui fait 10
microns ancien médecin dans un
ordinateur
alors c'est nucléotides là il ya des
parties des séquences de nucléotides qui
vont codé pour une partie d'une protéine
on appelle ça des exempts et il ya
d'autres séquences de nucléotides qui
codent popol et protéines on appelle ça
des intrants alors le génome complet
humain a été séquencé ça a pris 13 ans
faire ça ç'a pris des centaines de
laboratoires à travers le monde ça a
coûté 3 milliards de dollars pour faire
la séquence des trois points 3 milliards
de nucléotides qui constituent ce génome
humain et qui code pour vingt mille
jeunes c'est-à-dire 20000 protéines
différentes têtes même plus de protéines
que cela parce que plusieurs gènes
codent pour plusieurs protéines c'est
assez complexe
la bonne nouvelle c'est que maintenant
la capacité de séquencer le génome
humain a augmenté de façon fantastique
on est capable de séquencer 100000
nucléotides par seconde alors on est
maintenant capable dans un seul
laboratoire de séquencer en parallèle
sud génome humain entre seulement trop
beaux jours pour mille dollars a bien
commencé tune progrès vraiment
fantastique ce progrès vraiment
phénoménal ont permis par contre
d'identifier des mutations qui sont
responsables de 7000 maladies
héréditaires
alors ça c'est un exemple d'une partie
du d'un gène celui qui code pour une
protéine qui s'appelle la fra thaksin en
fait une protéine qui est muté dans
l'ataxie de friedreich week se gêne là
il est constitué de 76 1616 nucléotides
on peut trouver exactement la séquence
de ses nus clio de ces deux là sont bons
sur le bon site web en par internet
ici je vous ai mis juste les 1500
premiers à la fin de mon coin y aura un
test pour savoir si vous les avez retenu
alors cet adn là il est on en fait une
copie pour le traduire en protéines par
la suite cette copie ça s'appelle un arn
donc c'est une copie qui va être
maintenant non pas à double brême à un
seul brin qui vont être amenés du noyau
vers le site aux places de la cellule
pour permettre la synthèse des protéines
et comme on a 20 acides aminés
différents et qu'on a jusqu'à truc les
otites bien il faut un code en fait le
code ce qu'on veut
loyers croît nucléotides à la fois pour
coder pour un acide aminé données alors
voyez ici qu'on était en train
d'assembler oups on est en train
d'assembler une protéine différents
acides aminés qui sont attachés au 6 qui
dépendent d'une séquence qui est roi
nucléotides qu'on appelle un code envoyé
le prochain code on va permettre de
rassembler ici unanime alors donc ce
code génétique là il est connu depuis
des années en fait il est très similaire
dans les bactéries les plantes les
humains et cetera et ce qui est bien à
table c'est que parfois ils voyaient
ainsi qu'on a des certains cadeaux qui
code pour un code honda reste à dire ça
dit c'est là que la tête la protéine se
termine à ce qui est important de noter
c'est que des fois il suffit de changer
aujourd'hui de vous dire que dans les
arènes le thé est remplacé par un hub
parent uracile de tempête
le médecin est remplacé par united mais
ce qui est important de noter ici c'est
qu'on a ici un coton qui code pour une
psy rosine mais on fait je changeais le
sépare un as et à place de son intro
dont d'arrêt et ce qui peut arriver dans
le génome humain ce que des fois on a
des mutations une seul nucléotide qui
échanger en une maladie génétique aussi
bête que ça
alors les protéines bas c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que l'adn ça des formes
extrêmement variables certaines sont son
transmembranaire d'autres sont à
l'intérieur de la cellule et jour tous
des rôles importants alors parmi les
légendes de mutation qui sont
responsables de maladies génétiques
les mutations spontus ponctuelles un
seul nucléotide qui ait changé
des fois il peut y avoir une délétion
d'un seul nucléotide et comme savez
comme l'écho dont c'est lui trois à la
fois vous enlever un nucléotide vous ne
changez la séquence de toutes les autres
cordons qui suivait venait de changer la
composition de la protéine et puis elle
ne fonctionnera pas et souvent on va
avoir un code on stoppe qui doit être
rencontré au lieu d'avoir un cordon qui
code pour un acide aminé donc il peut y
avoir d'élections dans un nucléotide
parfois de milliers de nucléotides et il
peut y avoir insertion d'un nucléotides
ou de plusieurs milliers de nucléotides
et voyez qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
que maintenant qu ici on avait
j'aime non mutés on avait une
incorporation d'une alanine on a je
changeais un nucléotide et au lieu
d'avoir une anodine on voit un problème
qui peut être incorporé par dont
l'habitation était ici on avait un lieu
si neil ont remplacé par le projet donc
voyez que changer juste un nucléotide
parfois ça peut vraiment changer une
protéine ici on use et lui ce qui se
passe quand on a muté puis en un coup
d'arrêt la protéine se termine alors
depuis de nombreuses années il ya
beaucoup de chercheurs qui travaillent à
développer des thérapies géniques c'est
à dire la proche sur lesquels la
chercheurs travaillent depuis au moins
une bonne trentaine d'années c'est de
livrer un gène normal pour compenser
pour un gène muté alors ça c'est une
thérapie approches thérapeutiques
possibles pour des maladies qui sont
récessif c'est à dire des maladies ou
les deux copies du gène on en reçoit une
copie de notre père une copie de notre
masse les deux copies du gène sont mutés
on va développer la maladie
par contre il ya parfois des maladies
qu'on dit dominante se dire qu'il suffit
qu'il y ait un seul gène le muter même
si on a notre copie qui est normal
on a quand même la maladie donc ce genre
d' approche de livrer un gène normal
peut compenser pour deux jeunes qui sont
mutés ben oui c'est une approche
possible c'est une approche qu'on peut
faire par différentes manières soit de
livrer des cellules normales des fois on
peut faire ça pour des firmes musculaire
soin de livrer des jeunes sous forme de
plasmides c'est simplement de l'adn nu
et finalement ce qui est très employé
c'est d'utiliser des vecteurs viraux
c'est à dire les pires on sait tous que
ça nous cause des maladies mais ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on enlève les jeunes à
l'intérieur du virus on les remplace par
le gêne qu'on veut libre et la place et
les virus for soit ils sont habitués à
s'attacher des cellules rentrer leur
matériel génétique arrêté à des cellules
et donc c'est notre façon de livrer les
jeunes à l'intérieur des cellules
et finalement on va parler un peu plus
tard dans ma conférence de maintenant on
est capable de corriger des jeunes par
une nouvelle technologie qui s'appelle
s'est fait peur alors il ya déjà des
succès de thérapie génique vais
peut-être entendu parler des enfants
bulls et des enfants qui doivent vivre
en isolation même de leurs parents parce
que leur système humain est défectueux
il ya un jeune qui est défectueux qui
cote code pour une protéine anormale
fonctionne pas et à cause de ça ils sont
pas capables de défendre contre des
infections de piran ou des infections
bactériennes et donc ces gens là
d'autres vivre complètement isolation la
bonne nouvelle c'est que maintenant
beaucoup de ces patients là peuvent être
guéris en prenant les cellules souches
hématopoïétiques stasi des cellules qui
sont dans leur moelle osseuse
on prend ses soldats on les cultive on
rentre un gène normal peut compenser
pour le gène muté hors mais c'est
celle-là aux patients les patients sont
guéris et pour ce genre de traitement là
comme pour plusieurs autres un des virus
qu'on utilise beaucoup c'est le virus
associé à la démo virus parce que six
petits jours 25 nanomètres de gros seins
et surtout c'est un virus qui causent
pas de maladie chez les humains donc au
départ un virus qui était très
sécuritaire
je vais vous montrer un exemple que j'ai
vu dans la conférence l'année passée
anakin society of gene and cell therapy
5 au congrès international aux états
unis qui regroupe des milliers de
chercheurs avaient en thérapie génique
c'est le traitement d'une maladie
héréditaire qui s'appelle l'amaurose
congénitale de leber
c'est à dire c'est des gens qui voient
porte parce qu'il ya juste un gène qui
est muté le gène qui est muté basse et
exprime protéines qui s'exprime dans les
cellules de la rétine de l'oeil alors
ces patients-là ont été traitées
simplement en injectant dans l'oreille
un virus hin1 de nos sociétés de barrès
qui code pour le gène de la protéine
alors on nous montre ici un enfant qui
est de 7 8 ans à peu près on doit
rentrer à l'hôpital avec sa mère tient
seulement par lebron cannes en avant
parce que y est aveugle il voit pas
alors donc c'est l'enfant qui équivaut à
être traité pour cette maladie là on
nous dit qu à l'école quand il doit
travailler avec du braille parce que ils
voient pas où une voie propre et peu
près pas
hawx vidéo ok on ne montre le même
enfant deux ans plus tard est en train
de faire du bricolage
il conduit son boutique ils se lancent
la balle avec son père il peut même
rattraper et il faisait des minutes
il joue même aux honnêtes ndo alors il a
maintenant une vie normale et il avait
une cécité héréditaire qui n'était pas
guérissable auparavant et qui maintenant
peut-être guérir alors donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de recherche qui se
fait en thérapie génique actuellement
pour différentes sortes de maladies
héréditaires de les yeux et il ya
beaucoup de progrès de ce côté là il ya
aussi le premier traitement de thérapie
génique est approuvée par commerce pour
commercialisation
c'est un traitement pour une carence en
eau dans une protéine qui s'appelle la
lipoprotéine lipase ce traitement n'a
été conçu par un clinicien docteur godin
qui est de la région de saguenay au
québec mais les essais cliniques et la
commercialisation a été faite aux pays
bas pourquoi la sq au québec il n'a pas
trouvé le financement pour faire ce
genre de recherches là c'est le premier
traitement approuvé commercialement pour
thérapie génique partout à travers le
monde il ya d'autres traitements ou un
autre succès aussi ce traitement de
l'hémophilie c'est à dire des gens qui
saigne question non pas un facteur de
coagulation qui s'appelle le facteur 9
encore une fois on leur injecte un virus
on a des noces aussi et tout bas russe
qui code pour le facteur neuf et ils
sont guéris là c'est une question
d'examen qui s'en vient vous avez deux
souris la souris a hélas uribe et vous
allez me dire laquelle de ces deux
souris da est atteinte de l'ataxie de
friedreich d'une maladie qui donne des
problèmes de coordination des problèmes
nos mouvements et vous allez pouvoir me
dire laquelle de ces deux sauts vida es
vraiment atteint on a de nouveau la
souris a hélas uribe alors la question
vous laver les mains est ce que c'est la
souris à qui est atteinte de l'ataxie de
friedreich et est ce que la souris b est
atteint de l'ataxie de friedreich vous
êtes tous mauvais parce que la souris bl
est aussi atteinte de taxi friedreich
monde le traité avec un virus quand elle
était jeune et elle est guérie c'est
vraiment spectaculaire je fais de la
recherche depuis nombreuses années puis
je vous dire que c'est quand même les
résultats les plus marquants que j'ai
obtenus on essaie de pousser s'avère un
essai clinique pour les patients mais
comme d'habitude ce qui manque c'est le
financement
alors on nous montre ici la souris qui
peut quand même tout à fait guéri
normalement faisaient du mouvement comme
ça sont des mouvements quand même
anormaux pour cette souris là alors
jusqu'à présent je vais parler de
thérapies géniques où on introduit un
gène normal pour compenser pour un gène
muté mais ce qui est vraiment
révolutionnaire depuis deux ans d'une
nouvelle technologie qu'on appelle le
système cluster pour kloster avec
l'autorité ce pays
en fait je m'en souviens jamais
heureusement que c'est écrit là est un
soc 4 fantastiques ce que ça vient des
bactéries les bactéries se servent de ce
système n'a depuis des millions d'années
pour se défendre contre les infections
par des virus qui infecte les bactéries
et on a découvert ça dans les dernières
années est vraiment cette découverte la
date de deux ans qu'on peut se servir de
système n'a pour muter des gènes humains
ou des jeunes de plantes ou des jeunes
de d'animaux et en l'espace de deux ans
il ya 1900 publications scientifiques
qui ont été faits sur cette affaire là
alors donc l'idée de ce système là c'est
tout simplement qu'on emploie ce qu'on
appelle un arn guide qui a une vingtaine
de nucléotides qui sont complémentaires
une vingtaine de nucléotides qu'on cible
dans l'adn alors de ses anciennes mon
match aussi que ça va venir
il faut qu'une séquence ci qui est mg g
et par la suite le reste du lieu de ce
gag d'arena ou de se targuer de l'année
constats et ça va faire un complexe avec
une protéine qui s'appelle casse nine
c'est une clé à c'est une protéine qui a
pour rôle de couper l'adn et ce complexe
là bas se faire juste quand il ya
vraiment un bon match entre
la rn guide et l'adn qui est ciblé alors
une fois qu'on a coupé un adn comme ça
il ya deux choses qui peut se passer
mais qu'on aimerait adn qu'on a coupé
ici avec notre duke les as de type casna
les coupés par la suite on peut soit
avoir des microdélétion et des micros
insertion c'est utilisé pour un des
jeunes non fonctionnels parce que quand
des micros et insertion d microdélétion
souvent le nombre de nucléotides qui est
introduit n'est pas un multiple de 3
nucléotides le cadre de lecture des
codes on va changer qui s'apparente à
une protéine non fonctionnels donc on
peut se servir de tout facilement pour
faire des souris modèles pour
différentes maladies ou aura des jeunes
non fonctionnel mais surtout ce qui nous
intéresse c'est qu'on peut aussi faire
ce qu'on appelle une recombinaison
homologue sérieux qui font ce qu'il faut
faire c'est de fournir une séquence de
l'adn qui a des nucléotides qui sont les
mêmes que ce qui précède la coupure et
des nucléotides qui sont les mêmes que
ce qui suit la coupure et entre les deux
on peut introduire la séquence de
nucléotides qu'on veut et à ce moment là
ça nous donne un gène qui est corrigé
cette technologie dock permet de changer
exactement les nucléotides qu'on veut
alors on voit un petit quart tourne ici
qui nous montre cette protéine casse
nine elle contenait la dé la rn guide
qui vient s'hybrider donc avec l'adn
vient ouvrir cet adn lie s'hybrider avec
et une fois qu'on a un bon match chine
qui est fait vous voyez que l'adn et les
couper cet endroit là ici et une fois
que l'adn est coupée maillot des
nucléotides qui peuvent être perdus de
part et d'autre de cette coupure là et
parfois donc ce père spontanément il va
y avoir une réparation spontanée comme
je le mentionnais où il ya introduction
d'un nombre variable de nucléotides
par contre l'autre approche et que je
suis va suite à la coupure il peut y
avoir des pertes de nucléotides encore
une fois dans l'es2 brun mais si on a
fourni un brin d'aden qui s'en vient
voyez qu'on un brin d'aden qui s'en
vient ici qui contient des séquences qui
sont complémentaires et ce qui existait
déjà des séquences qu'on complémentaires
ce qui suivait ici et entre les deux on
a introduit exactement de séquences
qu'on veut
on vient de modifier un jeune sous vos
yeux ça vient d'arriver alors commencé à
utiliser cette technologie jeune je
travaille depuis des années sur
différentes maladies héréditaires sur la
dystrophie musculaire de duchenne sur
l'ataxie de friedreich et plus récemment
sur la maladie d'alzheimer
mais cette technologie doivent être
pouvoir s'appliquer aux 7000 maladies
génétiques qu'on connaît pas ce que
c'est juste toujours soin de corriger
nucléotides soin d'introduire un
nucléotide soit dans le vimeu la
technologie va fonctionner pour tout ça
je vous donne un exemple je suis ici
pour la maladie d'alzheimer se fait
parfois que des déjà qui développe une
maladie d'alzheimer dès l'âge de 40 45
ihome formes héréditaires la maladie
d'alzheimer à ce qui se passe c'est que
normalement on a une protéine qui est
situé voyez ça c'est la membrane des
neurones du système nerveux alors une
protéine qui est des deux côtés de la
membrane ce s'appelle amyloid precursor
protein alors cette protéine l'als est
normalement dégradé par un enzyme qui
s'appelle une alpha secretase qui vient
couper ici ça produit un fragment et
d'autres fragments qui sont ici tous ces
fragments là sont dégradées sa cause pas
de problème
mettre tintin la protéine a peut être
coupée par un autre enzyme qui s'appelle
une beta secrétases et par la suite c
coupé par un autant une qui s'appelle le
gamma sécrétase se forme ainsi fragments
de protéine qui au juste quarante à
quarante deux acides aminés de longueur
et se fraie demande aux protéines là ils
agrègent les unes aux autres et sa forme
des plaques dans le cerveau se met entre
les neurones ce sommet entre les
contacts que l'est du rhône font entre
autres qu'on appelle des synapses et la
belle anne et moi commence a moins bien
fonctionné les neurones marc et la
maladie progresse à tout ça c'est parce
que on coupe avec la beta secrétases un
premier au lieu de couper avec l'alfa
secrétaire alors il ya de nombreuses
mutations dans cette protéine la voyez
ça ici c'est une séquence des acides
aminés dans cette protéine là juste pour
une partie de la protéine qui est la
partie qui parle justement travers la
membrane et tous les endroits où on a
des étoiles
c'est des endroits où il ya eu des
mutations ces mutations sont
habituellement proches des sites de la
beta secrétases l'alpha sécrétase gamma
sécrétase qui est ici et toutes ces
mutations la font en sorte que les gens
développent mais la magie des âmes
alors ici j'ai pointé avec une flèche
rouge un acide aminé qui nous intéresse
est unanime dans la plupart d'entre nous
mais il ya eu un essai il ya eu une
étude de population qui a été fait en
suède
on a analysé ce gène hla dans des
personnes de plus de 95 ans qui n'avait
pas la maladie d'alzheimer
ils sont aperçus que chez ces patients
là la ligne n était remplacée par une
trio nine est ce que ça fait comme cette
année là il est situé très proche du
site de coupure par la beta secrétases
ça fait en sorte que la beta secrétases
et moins capable de couper c'est les
moins capables de couper il ya moins de
formation de ces peptides de 40 à 42 ans
et dominique cause des problèmes par
contre d'autres assez dominique sont
tout près de cet endroit là s'ils sont
mutés pour un autre acide aminé comme
ici maintenant que la ligne n est muté
pour une balle in plutôt qu'une trio
niel long contraire on développe une
maladie génétique parce que la beta
secrétases à coupe plus facilement alors
donc ce qu'on a fait dans mon
laboratoire jusqu'à présent c'est de
prendre des cellules humaines donc on
voit ici c'est un schéma de noter qu on
cesse de la protéine amyloid precursor
protein alors ça contient normale dans
nos cellules sa contenait une à lénine
qui on a développé un arn guide qui
vient reconnaître une séquence tout près
de là alors ça nous permet de couper le
jeune ici ont fourni par la suite un adn
d'honneur qui va contenir une très
honnête qui va contenir le code
génétique pour une terrienne plutôt que
pour l'analyse et d'autres mutations
sont introduites ici pour nous permettre
de reconnaître qu'on a fait et on peut
même introduire une mutation dans
l'instant qui suit pour faire en sorte
que nos jeunes peuvent être coupés par
un ancien de restriction alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est que on a réalisé c'était
cette mutation là dans des cellules
n et on peut montrer par la suite on
peut vraiment séquences et on voit ici
la séquence normale
walton et on voit ici la séquence muté
on voit que des nucléotides qui ont été
changés on voit aussi que dans les
troncs normalement n'avait cette
séquence l'art ne changeait de
nucléotides et support offert un nouveau
site de couper pour un ancien de
restrictions le message c'est qu'avec
cette technologie là on est capable
d'aller changer les nucléotides qu'on
veut dans un génome même si on a 6
milliards de nucléotides à l'intérieur
d'une cellule
c'est extraordinaire je pensais jamais
que je verrai ça dans mon vivant
quand j'ai commencé à faire de la
recherche mondiale sont peu séquencé le
génome humain avant que je viens de
naître
comment que je m'arrête bay surpris
d'autres non seulement la séquence du
génome humain mais maintenant il ya des
projets de recherche pour séquencer 1000
génomes humains ou même plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de ces deux génomes
humains tout ça va nous permettre de
comparer ces génomes là et d'identifier
des changements qui sont responsables de
maladies génétiques
il ya énormément de différence entre
votre génome chacun d'entre vous avez
des différences dans votre vie nombre ce
secret qui en a qui on est plus pointu
que d'autres la donne une excuse mais
c'est ce qui fait aussi que parfois de
certaines de ces modifications la sont
responsables d'une maladie génétique et
en fait chaque jour dans chacun d'entre
vous il ya 100 miel mutation qui se
passe par jour des milliards de cellules
à l'intérieur de notre présent times une
commutation il en reste cinq mutations
différentes par jour et certaines de ces
mutations l'eau fait en sorte qu'on
développe des cancers on sert maintenant
aussi de cette technologie la dent
l'ataxie de friedreich l'anomalie c'est
que on à l'examen qui est ici l'exemple
de sa code pour la protéine fera thaksin
mais entre les deux dans l'ain tron dans
une partie qui code pour la protéine on
a une longue répétition de tintry
nucléotides qui s'appelle gérard agera
en fait normalement chez les individus
normaux nahd
34 répétition comme ça mais chez les
patients on à 250 da trouvait au milieu
répétition de gea
ça fait en sorte que moins de frais
thaksin de produits on a plus de
difficultés à produire le messager reina
est une des approches sur lesquels on a
déjà réalisés dans le laboratoire c'est
de couper ici de koupéla enlevé le
morceau qui est trop puis dans une
sphère la gêne que le morceau et paul
hop ça marche bien mieux alors voyez
comment on peut appliquer ce genre de
technologie da à différentes approches
il ya à saint-hyacinthe à l'école de
médecine vétérinaire une facilité qu'ils
appellent bas opté repris pour doc sognu
nettement aux français
c'est un laboratoire qui a coûté 6
millions de dollars à construire oui
toute l'équipe manquait là dedans ça a
été construit le disait ça n'a jamais
servi
ça n'a jamais servi pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont une faune une subvention
les instituts canadiens de recherche en
excuses et du fonds canadien pour
l'innovation pour construire cette
facilité là mais par la suite les
chercheurs qui avaient fait la demande
n'ont jamais obtenu de subvention pour
la faire fonctionner c'est dramatique
comme ça maintenant l'équipe manquait là
dedans il y a pas ces dates les
garanties sont finies pour remettre ça
en fonction s'attendre à au moins 500 à
1000 $ et ça servirait à quoi ça
servirait à produire des vecteurs viraux
pour rentrer des jeunes normaux pour
compenser pour les gènes mutés ou la
technologie que je vous ai montré tantôt
d'essayer d'utiliser cette technologie
des crises peur mais il faut entrer le
gène la casse nine il faut rentrer l'adn
normal qu d'un pour rentrer le gène
codant pour la rn guide tous assez libre
et par des vecteurs viraux qui pourrait
être produit dans cette facilité là pour
développer éventuellement des thérapies
génique pour les maladies héréditaires
qui sont au québec on en a de nombreuses
maladies héréditaires au québec à cause
de ce qu'on appelle un effet fondateur
vous savez il ya eu très peu de colons
français qui sont venus ici au début
peut formuler l'après population
québécoise
parmi ces colons français là il y en a
des qui avaient des gènes récessifs il
en avait juste une copie votre problème
il n'avait pas la maladie mais
éventuellement faire se reproduire il
yad'autres dompter des mâles et des
femelles qui sont mariés ensemble qu'ils
avaient des
gène récessif et donc à ce moment-là on
développe la maladie héréditaire c'est
pour ça qu'au saguenay nombreuses
maladies héréditaires et je pense
sérieusement à poursuivre la france pour
nous avoir envoyé des gens au début qui
était avait des mauvais gènes alors le
message c'est qu'on rentre maintenant
dans une ère où on peut espérer
développer des traitements pour beaucoup
de maladies génétiques
le principal problème le principal
limitation
c'est les subventions pour ce genre de
recherches là et je peux vous dire que
le gouvernement actuel ne nous est pas
particulièrement
donc il faut au québec la raison pour
laquelle j'ai accepté de donner une
conférence ici c'est qu'il faut que les
gens soient au courant de ce qui se
passe dans les laboratoires qu'on est
capable de développer des thérapies pour
ce genre de maladie là il faut qu'il ya
une reconnaissance des gouvernements
canadien et provinciaux pour reconnaître
que ça existe des maladies génétiques
chacun de ces maladies génétiques là
elle saura en à 7000 différente quand on
les regroupe tout ça ces responsables de
maladies génétiques sur 7 8% de la
population canadienne
c'est pas un problème ras c'est un gros
problème pour l'ensemble de la
population
et si on pouvait traiter ces gens là par
des traitements qui offre des solutions
permanentes une guérison
ce serait des gens qui éventuellement
coûterait moins cher au système de santé
que les gardes des malades
mais pour réussir sa ce qu'il faut c'est
d'avoir les subventions pour pouvoir
continuer ce genre de recherches là pour
faire en sorte que les facilités qui ont
été battus pour 10 millions de dollars à
saint-hyacinthe plus vraiment fonctionné
merci merci monsieur tremblay
merci